two other questions around Bitcoin I
guess one is like do you think it could
rise to become the global Reserve
currency and whether that's you know
1500 even 500 years from now like is the
expectation that there would be
decentralized money as the the core unit
of account and kind of store value
globally or do you think that we'll just
get more and more fragmentation and the
Fiat currencies they'll be decentralized
uh you know currency like Bitcoin maybe
there's even these private currencies
that some of these companies have tried
to create like how do you think this
plays out it's hard to know I mean
biology has got this framework where
there's basically only three currencies
that have scale
um one is the USD sort of the USD
American Empire then there's
um China the remember uh and then
there's Bitcoin and sort of crypto world
and he thinks those are the only three
currencies that can get to sufficient
scale to be some sort of world Reserve
currency
um I don't know what happens I mean I
think that I think the question is can
you get to something where Bitcoin is
widely used without there being like
basically a US US dollar collapsed or
something catastrophic happening I don't
know the answer to that I think there
are sort of middle scenarios where
um you know if you're in a country that
had uh that with like a totalitarian
government or something like that or had
export controls or was extremely
repressive or is being invaded and going
through a war you'd want to move as much
your net worth into Bitcoin as you could
despite the price volatility because
it's portable you can take it with you
um so in that you know it's the new
diamonds it's new gold bars whatever so
there's sort of that store value
argument even short of it being a Fiat
currency
um but I think it's I think it's
interesting you know
um
it's uh what we're talking about I I
didn't coin this phrase but the
separation of money and state you know
we and if that happens that would be as
big an event as the separation of church
and state you know the Church of State
used to be intrinsically linked and
combined you couldn't really think about
the two without them being together now
we think about them being separate I
think money and stays kind of like that
we can't really think of money without
the state but Bitcoin it's sort of this
like sci-fi future where you could maybe
have these two things
uh decoupled
um
you know I don't know how long that
takes I don't you know it and it's also
it's very hard to know like what price
you should put on that you know which is
why I don't like actively speculate on
it because
um I just don't know what the price
level should be yeah do you uh still buy
Bitcoin like over time just as like hey
I'm just dollar cost averaging or is
this something where hey I bought some
early on that's what I got and you know
I'm gonna go focus on SAS investing or
like how do you think about it yeah so I
have a position in it and my view is
kind of to set it and forget it I've
seen so many ups and downs at this point
that I'm just like look I'm gonna put
this amount of money in Bitcoin and it's
some percentage of my net worth I'm just
gonna leave it alone and maybe it'll be
worth nothing but maybe this will become
new money over the next 20 years and in
which case I'll feel really stupid if I
didn't buy in at a much earlier stage so
I I've kind of got like a little piece
there and just I just leave it alone and
don't try to figure out like these price
moves last thing on bitcoin is
um there's a very large portion of
people in the Bitcoin crypto world that
are Bitcoin maximalists and so they
believe hey Bitcoin is the only thing
everything else is a [ __ ] coin it's all
going to zero uh I don't think you're in
that category given some of the
Investments I know that you've made
um what is your argument for or against
kind of that maximalistic view when it
comes to something like money is it
something that you understand but you're
like hey I'm an investor and I want to
go also find Productive assets is it
something really I don't understand you
know that view of the world just talking
about that
yeah I mean I wouldn't say I'm a
maximalist
um I think that the case for Bitcoin is
probably the strongest of all the
cryptos and the price and relative
stability reflects that but
um look you have in the process of
creating Bitcoin you have these new
other new technologies arise like the
blockchain itself and why couldn't you
use that to support other you know
Innovations and so the most obvious one
being you know the idea of a smart
contract platform and so now you have
kind of these other cryptos that
function as gas to basically buy
computing power on a smart contract
platform like you know like ethereum
like Solana
that's the space and then there's all
the various applications that
potentially could be run on a blockchain
which mainly you've seen in terms of
ones that have scale it's mostly just
defy you know it's
um mostly Financial contracts or various
kinds and financial speculation
um I think what remains to to be seen is
what is the breadth of the applications
that can ultimately be built on top of
blockchains but I think
part in in the exuberance over these
types of platforms I think there's like
too many things that actually don't
really make a lot of sense where now
you're just better off using a
centralized database so the breath Still
Remains to be seen but I think what's
interesting is
just the financial contracts the
settlement system the way that you could
do derivatives things like that it's so
much more transparent than what you
could get on Wall Street where they're
giving you these like OTC derivatives
where you don't really understand what
they are at least with the blockchain
with D5 you can inspect the code so it
does seem like a better way to do
trading
and we'll see where it evolves to from
here
uh but I guess I think I'm not totally
sure about is the range of applications
that are ultimately gonna emerge